what's going on guys we're here with the
official Catwoman character breakdown
from nether realm now this was taken
from a live stream so if you see
anything that seems a little off
remember that it's a work in progress
and don't forget to Like and subscribe
to keep up to date with all of our
injustice - coverage a great - a great
job she has some great jump attacks but
in the original game her walking was
someone on the slow side and a lot of
Catwoman had players uh you know they
had some trouble in some matches so yeah
I like how you say some cats I mean uh
you're telling about yourself but her
walk is completely changed it is now
significantly faster so that definitely
helps out her mobility which makes sense
because she has a rush down character
instead of saying her you should say
mine I speak for all cabinet okay okay
cool that's that's something I call our
player base the litter mmm hey all right
Steve Lissa what did she do
so as I said she's a long-range
character and one of the changes we made
to is her 41 which is a great attack is
now a mid instead of an overhead so
while her mobility is better her mix-ups
are not quite as overpowering as they
were before so this is still a great
attack with a lot of range you can go
into a combo but it's no longer and over
an attack instead she's gonna happen
this or her new for three new for three
so she could still use that she could
still use her back one to open you up
but for Ford one's not gonna be a mix of
20 more it's gonna be arranged to her
she still has her whip trip
this she still has her great jump too
you see we loose right I did that was an
accident and of course her back three
which is a low profiling long range back
we attack I would say it is my favorite
back three to connect it is very very
it's very very it feels good she also
has some cool mobility options her her
meter burn role is not a role look at
this oh I didn't know that
that's emailing about every confetti
that's fun so happy yeah like this is
like this is not fake I love
authenticity we our favorite things
Steve okay alright
Steven very very excited right now to a
point that I haven't seen in a while
wow she has she has a new throw yes she
has a new throw which is really you know
things are going off the rails when
Derrick's like guys come on Steven it's
too much
alright so and most of her special
attacks or bang her cat dashes back
however you'll notice she has to use a
bar of meter to come now they just get
knocked down but it used the bar meter
you get the traditional lost weight
three yeah let's look at the way through
she has her whip attacks including the
entire one I can't jump you never could
that's because all the girls struck as
battering there we go
Carrie alright she has her cat stance
and the three options from it to pounce
I like AI way to show that people didn't
think that I can get out of the air
right there are always squares there are
new players who have not experienced the
joys of playing Selena and they're
interesting there's at least one person
that's true who didn't know about the
past
you're right now I find that they gotta
whip air with so now let's upwind just
keep going to second okay so let's talk
about her new move replacing her old cat
claws move is the rising claws which is
a big anti-air leaping air attack now
normally she does not get a combo but if
you meter burnin and launches and then
she pops keep owning up like we've spent
hours playing would you say this is a
good way cover new here that's the big
thing
one of the problems with cat one in part
one is other than a character power she
did not have a fully invincible lake of
attack this rising claw is so that's a
great change that's a perfect example of
she feels fresh wall you know having a
lot of her strengths for karma and let
me let me say where we had we have mr.
Matt Gilmore on the stream while back
from from FX I love the purple cloth I
love the slightly so yeah a good job T
FX theme on that so let's go over care
car there's open a lot of speculation
about it it is bad yeah ah she still
builds scratches for landing moves
including special moves oh there's a
chance every time she lands an attack
she has a random chance of getting a
scratch you can see I'm building them
there right yep and then she has an auto
combo that she does when she have
scratches so I'll build like to probably
three and then the character power she
does a combo and this is a brand new
combo it's very different than the one
in part one so it'll have a ton of stuff
you can explore digging home
different hit advantage different damage
different block advantage and we have
all five it's five hits that's man and
let's talk about something to that I
mean really big a big quality of life
thing we've mentioned before but in case
you haven't seen it now in our practice
mode you can actually kind of turn on or
change what the character power will do
so you can actually train with it on yes
you don't have to sit there and get all
five scratches or two scratches the
crews three expressions you can sat down
in training and straighten them before
this option I would have to pick a
character control them to do fireballs
sure she could evade them and then get
the scratches you didn't say that to you
proving her evade his back and the low
evade and she still builds a scratch for
successfully evade another new normal
attack I got sidetracked is we're back
to which is a great super fast
long-range mid look at that look at the
range of this and it leads to a full
string you can either go into a combo or
you can do the pull string very cool
looking very very good move again it
brings up she's a long-range melee
character the opponent she plays her
rush down game from this distance and
that's what makes her so strong yeah so
there's even more to her character power
she has the ability to meter burn it now
and get even more hits and more combos
say what duty
[Music]
so this is a great combo a big chunk of
damage or if you're not good at combos
and you knew the game I'd be good at
this ANBU combo yeah yeah that's a great
combo you and you can just do forward
one into it
get very respectable damage I'll tell
you what though I've been through the
way I could drop that I bet there is I I
would find a way Steve alright so let's
talk about her super moon that's all
with Kerri yeah that is that's her
character power cool right basically the
more she does the the better she does at
what she does was his rust down rush
down the more scratches she gets and
then when she gets a big combo going
it's for Tom to to trot the combo and to
go for the coup de Gras coup de gras do
you everything give me a swaggerific
thing for the quarter I mean I can do
the classic combo see the classic throw
that for Thursday yeah if it works
No
[Music]
there we go that was pretty soon oh
thank you much damage but it looked
amazing fine so her super attack has a
really interesting start
she actually leaps up just dived in
first we'll watch it the whole time
[Music]
and she can actually control how far she
travels she can do a long one and she
can do short one and then the medium
lunch which I show so this is a great
super move this is one of the Subarus
where if you have all bars a meter the
opponent really has to be careful about
for example throwing batarangs from this
distance that wasn't really well that
missed but you get the ball
there's also set up so you can do you
can actually go over the opponent or you
can do a short one getting up you can
use it as a cross for executed gotcha
can we the stream is asking if we go
through the official mistake can we
insure can we do that Daddy we can do
that are you sure yeah I don't wanna hit
it again nice move I guess if they want
it please do a full combo in doing well
[Music]
that's worth anything extra life yet
million there's really good we are now
in the rock of eternity
nice alright I think he was laughing a
big profitable the lighting kind of oh
yeah this this level it looks incredible
so I believe you guys gonna back it away
yeah alright should we do it
take a look I can't believe we're doing
this
I don't think we got approval for this
yeah I put the stay they wanted it they
want fans wanted to give it it's true
alright so how about we look at some
loadouts yeah I'm guessing you've picked
some cool stuff I absolutely love her
here I have spent a obscene amount of
time in the customizable character menu
looking at her gear I will say a lot of
people oh wow on her on Twitter unread
on the forums they always want the
coolest gear and you look like you've
done some cool stuff yeah I love her
hood and her customizable whips and her
shoulder dancer accessories your whip
yes that is there's many different with
time including one of my favorites in
the next loadout that's a little
surprised so we have two abilities here
we have air cat - it's basically her
normal cat - but she doesn't the air so
this her air mobility is also great cuz
you have jumped to jump one now if she
jumps in the opponent for example does a
batter in no exid's on the better you
should have done the batteries nope
oh that's a head but there you go she
can go in and you can meet her burn at
any time just like the regular one so
from full screen you can go in and beat
them or you can actually go here let's
do the first one then meter burn when
you see that it hits so this is just an
extra way for half even better air
mobility than before and then she has
another cool one which is below with
which is a new special move where she
it's the loan and comes up that's a and
I absolutely love the meter
oh that's attitude she has a lot of
personality she does she's sassy
remember this how I beat you twice go
with babe I do remember that I do
remember that haven't I told that story
on screen before I feel like we tell it
every money but it needs to its
legendary yeah I beat Steve twice in a
row he got real salty that's the story
that was an amazing story that's so if
you were a CEO again always hold
excellent okay through now it's done
that was definitely the maddest I've
ever said about me I bet it is all right
so this definitely complements her game
if it's an opponent who is very good at
keeping her out and walking back like
say Aquaman or even Deadshot we showed
earlier the low whip will keep them on
their toes and do really significant
damage they're not gonna be able to just
walk away you're not walking away at all
oh I was too worried about throwing bit
awesome alright so la top three and this
is one of you the unit some cool stuff
here I absolutely love her whip here my
favorite part about this was when we
were setting it up we were going through
the colors and shakers and stuff and
seems like does this one look cool and I
was like yeah it looks really perfect
I'm cut they don't yeah I'm actually
colorblind
oh forgot about that alright does it
look like the other ones like no not at
all Stevie
great alright so here I gave her the
ability cat call where she summons her
cat and then the cat attacks and they
get opened up for a combo so this move
is incredibly useful it's a two slot
move she can summon the cat and then
she's free to move
so what will happen is she can summon
the cat Batman now has to walk and then
she can go in so Derek can you block I
can try and now you're free to do jump
ins you're free whip trip you're free to
do 43 whatever you can think of this
basically tells the opponent you need to
sit still or you're gonna get scratching
in the face and then if you get
scratched you get a compliment
[Music]
and let's be honest it absolutely looks
amazing and it's super fun and the cat
meows when she comes out so and then
it's with your because I'm a big fan of
the colored with I personally like the
neon pink with that's my personal I have
what I call ideal Catwoman which is my
personal mode out and it has the neon
pink whip again and a cloth got you so
tell me what color to the cat would look
like this looks red okay you're good
yeah I guess close you're right yeah
yeah yeah yeah so can we trust that he's
colorblind
I don't know again okay so that's
Catwoman I think fans of deflator and
part one would be very very happy
she's very similar but uh what's the
really fun tweaks that uh really play
into what made her fun to play in part
one
she seems like there's like some new
light in her yeah really yeah she feels
really kind of vibrant there's an appeal
to her oh there is and there are some
abilities that we're not showing
including arguably my favorite ability
in the game
for but we're not talking about we're
not talking about talking about it which
anyone was I don't know
alright so now Derek yes we got one